?
WHAT TOOK PLACE TONIGHT AGAINST
YOUR RIVAL ON THIS STAGE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO THINK
ABOUT IT.
ALL I KNOW IS THIS HAS BEEN A
GROUP OF PERSEVERANCE AND
TOUGHNESS AND RESILIENCY.
I'VE SAID THAT.
I SAID OVER THE LAST TWO, TWO
AND A HALF MONTHS, THIS GROUP IS
SO TOGETHER.
THE HELP OF THIS TEAM AND THIS
PROGRAM IS AT ITS FINEST AND I'M
JUST SO PROUD OF THEM.
SEEING THEM CONTINUE TO HAVE
EXPERIENCES AND TESTIMONIES AND
STORIES OUT THERE, I'M JUST
TELLING YOU, AS A COACH, IT
BRINGS SO MUCH JOY TO ME TO SEE
THESE GUYS HAVE A SMILE ON THEIR
FACE AND COME UP BIG THIS IS A
BEAUTIFUL MOMENT.
>> Tracy: HOW ABOUT FOR YOU, FOR
THIS PROGRAM, TO BRING IT BACK
TO WHERE YOU SAID YOU WANTED IT
TO BE?
I SEE THE TEARS.
WHERE DO THOSE COME FROM?
>> WELL, IT IS.
I TALKED TO YOU ABOUT IT THE
OTHER DAY, THAT I FELT LIKE OVER
THE LAST TWO, THREE YEARS, NORTH
CAROLINA WASN'T RELEVANT.
NORTH CAROLINA SHOULD NEVER BE
IRRELEVANT.
IT SHOULD BE FRONT AND CENTER
WITH THE SPOTLIGHT ON THEM, ON
PLAYERS LIKE CALEB AND R.J. AND
I JUST -- I'M SO HAPPY FOR THEM.
I'M SO HAPPY FOR OUR PROGRAM,
OUR UNIVERSITY.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL DAY FOR
CAROLINA BASKETBALL.
>> Tracy: THANK YOU.
AND I'LL BRING IN CALEB.
CALEB, JUST SIX POINTS IN THAT
FIRST HALF, 21 IN THE SECOND,
WHAT GOT INTO YOU HERE?
HOW BAD DID YOU WANT THIS ONE?
>> I WANTED IT BAD.
YOU KNOW, PLAYING DUKE, FOR A
CHANCE TO GET TO THE NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP, YOU KNOW, IT'S
CRAZY THAT I'M HERE RIGHT NOW,
I'M JUST BLESSED AND GLAD TO DO
IT WITH MY TEAMMATES.
>> Tracy: NOW YOU'RE ON TO WIN A
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP.
THAT IS YOUR GOAL ON MONDAY
NIGHT AGAINST KANSAS.
WHAT WILL IT TAKE FOR THIS TEAM
TO CARRY THIS INTO MONDAY NIGHT?
>> JUST OUR TOGETHERNESS AND OUR
TESTIFINESS.
KANSAS IS A GREAT TEAM.
THEY LIKE TO -- THEIR PACE IS
ONE OF THE TOP ONE IN THE NATION
AND SO, WE GOT TO STOP THEM IN
TRANSITION AND WE JUST GOT TO
PLAY OUR GAME.
>> Tracy: GO ENJOY THIS ONE.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
>> Jim: OUR VISIT THE OTHER
NIGHT WITH HUBERT, HE TALKED
ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO
HONOR COACH SMITH, COACH GUST
RIDGE, COACH WILLIAMS.
HE HAD TEERPS IN HIS EYES AS HE
TALKED ABOUT IT.
IT IS AN AMAZING ACHIEVEME